and we're in the carpet now joined by
Megan Patrick and her boyfriend Mitchell
Tenpenny great to see you guys and
welcome to see CMAs thank you I know
there's a lot of big things happening in
your life including you guys just bought
a new home in Nashville maybe it was a
love at first sight when you saw the
home um pretty much yeah for me to have
when I bought a house so yeah Mitchell
you're shaking your head though I know
you made love at first sight for me well
then let me ask you this question I want
you to finish a line for me if you can
okay first comes love then comes a house
[Music]
yeah absolutely
tell me how excited you are tonight you
of course are the reigning female artist
of the year Megan Patrick how would you
describe your life right now
not a lot of sleep really busy but I
mean I like being busy I mean being busy
means you're doing something right
so just been on the road a bunch I just
put my new EP out on Friday which I'm
getting a lot of great response from so
my life is pretty damn good right now
did you I just Instagram that your life
is full of dry shampoo and grilled
cheese that you yes a lot of grilled
cheese and dry shampoo it's a necessity
in this business all right well great to
see you both enjoy the evening thank you
so much